all right guys welcome to the software
part of this video and if you haven't
already click the h watching hd link
below this video to get the best quality
out of it so you can see exactly what
i'm doing i'm going to show you how to
put your computer in hibernate
obviously if you're in windows vista
this is going to be easy just by
clicking on this link here on the start
button going to the extras uh in the
shutdown the little arrow right there
and hibernate is right there i'm not
going to click it because i'll end the
video but you can see when i hover over
it it says it saves my session and shuts
down my computer and actually restores
it which actually completely shuts down
stops using power stop spinning the
hardness everything and will save you a
lot more battery life than just closing
and putting into sleep now if i've
already set this button here to shut
down instead of actually sleep but if
you want to set this to hibernate mode
you can actually go to control panel
and we're going to go to power options
in order to see what the button does so
let's go into i believe it's hardware
and sound
and we're going to go to power options
and change what the power buttons do and
obviously there's different settings for
on battery and plugged in but i've set
the power button to actually shut down
the laptop you can change this to
hibernate your laptop sorry
so that is how you set your laptop to
ship to hibernate when you set when you
actually press this red button here so
thanks for watching and i hope this was
helpful and i hope you save a ton more
battery life by watching these this
tutorial series thanks for watching
episode 5 and if you have any more
comments or questions about this uh
particular process just send me a
personal message after you subscribed
and i'll do my best in another video
thanks for watching peace